let's say we have a beaker of distilled
water at 25 degrees celsius and to the
beaker we add some barium sulfate barium
sulfate is a white solid
a small amount of the barium sulfate
dissolves in the water and forms barium
2 plus ions in solution and sulfate ions
in solution so let me draw those in on
our diagram so we're going to form some
barium 2 plus ions and some sulfate
anions
but most of the barium sulfate remains
undissolved and with that so we'll draw
that here sitting on the bottom of the
beaker
so barium sulfate can dissolve to form
barium two plus ions and sulfate anions
in solution and it's possible for the
barium two plus ion to combine with the
sulfate anion to form a precipitate of
barium sulfate when the rate of
dissolution is equal to the rate of
precipitation
the system is at equilibrium
these types of equilibria are referred
to as solubility equilibria and when the
system is at equilibrium the
concentrations of barium 2 plus ion and
sulfate anion in solution are constant
and the amount of solid is constant too
and this forms a saturated solution the
balanced equation shows the dissolution
of a salt barium sulfate and from the
balanced equation we can write an
equilibrium constant expression so we
would write the equilibrium constant k
is equal to the concentration of barium
two plus and since there's a coefficient
of one in the balanced equation it'd be
the concentration raised to the first
power times the concentration of sulfate
also raised to the first power
and since pure solids are left out of
equilibrium constant expressions we
would not include the solid barium
sulfate
for solubility equilibria we would write
ksp where sp stands for solubility
product the solubility product constant
ksp has only one value for a given salt
at a specific temperature that
temperature is usually 25 degrees
celsius and ksp indicates how much of
that salt will dissolve
for example at 25 degrees celsius the
ksp value for barium sulfate is 1.1
times 10 to the negative 10th when the
ksp value is much less than 1 that
indicates the salt is not very soluble
so barium sulfate is not a soluble salt
if the ksp value is greater than one
like it is for something like sodium
chloride that indicates a soluble salt
that dissolves easily in water the
solubility of a substance refers to the
amount of solid that dissolves to form a
saturated solution usually the units for
solubility are in grams per liter
molar solubility refers to the number of
moles of the solid that dissolve to form
one liter of the saturated solution and
therefore the units would be moles per
one liter or you could just write molar
ksp values can be used to predict the
relative solubilities of salts that
produce the same number of ions in
solution
for example silver chloride silver
bromide and silver iodide all produce
two ions in solution let's look at the
dissolution equation for silver chloride
to see why this is true solid silver
chloride turns into a g plus and cl
minus so that's one ag plus ion and one
cl minus ion for a total of two ions in
solution
and we could write out similar equations
for silver bromide and silver iodide so
they all produce two ions in solution
however a salt like lead to chloride
produces three ions in solution so lead
ii chloride would give one pb2 plus ion
and two chloride anions in solution one
plus two is three ions
since lead two chloride produces threons
three ions in solution we can't
determine its solubility relative to the
other three by comparing ksp values
here are the ksp values for the three
salts at 25 degrees celsius for silver
chloride it's 1.8 times 10 to the
negative 10th for silver bromide it's
5.0 times 10 to the negative 13th and
for silver iodide it's 8.3 times 10 to
the negative 17th when comparing salts
that produce the same number of ions the
higher the value of ksp the higher the
solubility of the salt
and since silver chloride has the
highest ksp value of these three silver
chloride is the most soluble salt
for some insight into why this is true
let's look at the ksp expression for
silver chloride which we can get from
the balanced equation the higher the
value for ksp the higher the
concentration of these ions at
equilibrium which means that more of the
solid must have dissolved therefore
silver chloride has the highest
solubility out of these three salts
let's say we have some solid calcium
fluoride that we add to pure water at 25
degrees celsius
eventually equilibrium is reached and
the equilibrium concentration of calcium
2 plus ions is measured to be 2.1 times
10 to the negative fourth molar our goal
is to calculate the ksp for calcium
fluoride at 25 degrees celsius the first
step is to write out the dissolution
equation for calcium fluoride so we
would write caf2 solid and we know that
calcium forms a two plus cation so we
would write ca2 plus
an aqueous solution
and to balance everything we'd need two
fluoride anions so two f minus also in
aqueous solution
the next step is to use the balanced
equation to write the ksp expression so
ksp is equal to
there's a one as a coefficient in front
of ca2 plus it would be the
concentration of ca2 plus raised to the
first power times the concentration of
fluoride anion and since there's a 2 as
a coefficient this is the concentration
of fluoride anion squared
for a ksp expression these are
equilibrium concentrations and we
already know the concentration of
calcium 2 plus at equilibrium is 2.1
times 10 to the negative fourth so that
can be plugged in for the equilibrium
concentration of ca2 plus
so here's our expression with 2.1 times
10 to the to the negative fourth plugged
in and next we need to plug in the
equilibrium concentration of fluoride
anion well looking at the dissolution
equation the mole ratio of calcium to
plus to fluoride anion is one to two
therefore at equilibrium there's twice
as many fluoride ions in solution as
there are calcium two plus ions
therefore the equilibrium concentration
of the fluoride anion would just be
twice this concentration for ca2 plus
so the
equilibrium concentration of fluoride
anion must be 4.2
times 10 to the negative fourth molar
and when you do the math you get that
ksp for calcium fluoride is equal to 3.7
times 10 to the negative 11th at 25
degrees celsius
ksp values can be difficult to measure
and therefore different sources often
give different values for ksp at the
same temperature for example for calcium
fluoride at 25 degrees celsius one
source had ksp equal to 3.5 times 10 to
the negative 11th another one had 3.9
times 10 to the negative 11th
since we got 3.7 times 10 to the
negative 11th this sounds like a pretty
good calculation for the numbers that we
used for our problem
finally let's think about the molar
solubility of calcium fluoride so how
many moles of our salt dissolve to form
one liter of our saturated solution
well the mole ratio of calcium two plus
ions to calcium fluoride is one to one
therefore the concentration of calcium
two plus ions in solution 2.1 times 10
to the negative fourth molar that number
must also be the molar solubility of
calcium fluoride therefore for this
problem we could say that we use the
molar solubility of calcium fluoride to
calculate the ksp value for calcium
fluoride